[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show we help you get control of your
money get ahead in your career and get
on the path to living well
i'm george campbell joined by
best-selling author ken coleman today
and we are taking your calls
[Music]
825-5225 if you're at a crossroads with
your money your life your career you've
got a toxic boss a toxic workplace
you're not sure what to do should you
sell the house we are here for you to
give you some confidence some
encouragement uh along the way triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you ready to go ken let's go we got to
get to help some people but later in the
show i want to talk about that denim
jacket oh that's for later i thought
ken's very persnickety on this friday
but i like it great word let's go let's
go well liam is waiting with baited
breath on the line in chicago liam
welcome to the show
hi guys thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
okay so here's the thing i've been in my
current employer since around 2014
um
i feel a little bit
you know i'm not passionate about the
work that i do
but
um it's a good job the people that i
work for are good people i have a good
boss he takes care of us
but um i think my life is defined more
than my current pay hourly wage
and i would like to make more because i
feel like i can't even afford the things
that i want to get for my wife
how much do you make right now liam um
all said and done it's around uh 45k a
year yeah man we you are worth so much
first of all there's no value you can
put on a human you're invaluable but as
far as your earning potential yeah man
we need to be doubling that and being on
a path to doing that soon how does that
sound
that's fair and all the only reason why
i am hesitant to even look for a lateral
move or something significantly more
is that my daughter has special needs
okay and the insurance of my employer
has been a lifesaver if i didn't have
the insurance sure we had for her we
would be destitute totally understood
brain surgeries oh my god for the age of
four oh my gosh how is her health right
now what is the long-term prognosis what
can they tell you what are they telling
you
well she was diagnosed uh for epilepsy
at 47 days old oh my goodness and um
we've been on and off each one of these
surgeries was there was some respite
and then it comes back
we just had a surgery
back in march okay so not real sure is
that the answer really not sure if or
how many surgeries yeah so it's possible
she should have she could have more
surgeries
if that or
just doctor said there's nothing else
they can do okay well first of all
my heart breaks as a as a daddy i get
that and i hate that and uh
and i understand the fear
but i want to challenge the fear a
little bit but i want to do it with some
numbers not with a rah-rah speech how
does that sound the sun's fair all right
now you have a pretty good idea
about what these surgeries and what
these procedures cost or you have a very
good idea of what percentage
of of the expenses that your current
health care plan and your benefits cover
correct you got a pretty good idea what
your deductible is so you you're a pro
at this now right oh yeah oh god yes
there we go so here's the deal as you
begin to look outward keep in mind we're
not leaving
we're not leaving
we're not going to put your benefits in
any kind of jeopardy at all
but what we are doing when we are
looking is we're going to have
conversations and we're going to say hey
what's the health plan like and you
don't have to lead with
my daughter has had all of these
surgeries that's none of their business
but you can ask informed questions in
the interview process and certainly when
somebody makes you an offer
and you can ask questions hey i want to
get a good idea benefits matter to me
people understand that that's not an
outrageous statement
and so you can find out you know the
trigger points that you're looking for
so you ask questions around those things
and my friend if it doesn't work
walk away
but you should be not only
confident
that other companies have very good
health care plans because they do
uh you should also be confident that you
making double what you're making right
now is also going to help out with any
medical expenses so i understand the
fear but i was talking about this today
on my show george and i'm just it's
fresh it's like the the hot now sign at
krispy kreme i just i just i mean 20
minutes ago talked to a caller about
this so so leo i'm going to teach this
to you because i think a lot of people
right now in this audience for a variety
of reasons are dealing with fear and
doubt
and liam i want to explain to you the
difference between fear and doubt
fear
is i'm afraid that something bad is
going to happen
doubt is i don't believe something good
can happen and i think you are
absolutely getting crushed the left hand
you know the fear monster is just
jabbing you right in the face i'm afraid
of financial ruin if i take another job
and my daughter has more health care
issues and and on and on it goes and
then doubts coming in with the right
cross over the top going you're not
going to find another company with
health care benefits like this
does that sound about right liam
that that sounds about right i know
here's the deal i don't i don't believe
i'm even educated you're not
you're not and that's the answer you
ready for this
when we have fear and doubt we need to
george we put them on paper and we write
them out so we can see what specifically
am i afraid of so liam you're not going
to make you do this on the air but this
is the exercise you have to write down i
am afraid of i doubt you write it down
now
underneath the voice of fear and doubt
folks you've got to understand that
there's something under the surface and
what's under the surface of fear and
doubt
is a lack of information
the unknown
and so when i look at the voice of fear
and i look at the voice of doubt and i
go okay
what's driving me nuts here
is that i've left
my brain to the vacuum of the unknown
and this all these horrible things are
running around like it's scary
all the what-ifs so what you have to do
liam in this case is specifically begin
to look out for jobs and look for health
care benefits and put yourself out there
knowing that we're gonna go date but we
don't have to marry a company and if we
faint find out it's the right marriage
and we get answers to the health care
question and we get answers to can i
grow in this job will somebody want me
will somebody pay me more than forty
thousand dollars a year you've got
several unknowns that you're allowing to
paralyze you like you're in a dark cave
and you can't see your face your hand in
front of your face and that paralyzes us
all so we shed light in the cave when we
put on the flashlight or we have a torch
now we can see and now we can move and
so you've got to do this right now you
have some specific questions that you
need answers to and george when he gets
those answers here's what happens
you get clarity
and then clarity breeds confidence and
confidence breeds courage to move
forward when i'm clear i'm confident
that i should go that i can go i know
how i'm going to go
and then when life throws the the next
surgery your way liam
we have courage to walk through it
because hey we've done the homework we
know where we're supposed to be we know
the income we can make and so that's
what i want to encourage you with
beautiful liam how do you feel
feels good
i'll take that like that start looking
today looking doesn't mean you're
leaving your safety we don't leave folks
financially the ramsay show we're never
going to tell you to leave close to the
dock yeah you just step onto it yeah
this is not an extreme sport and uh liam
hang on the line austin's going to pick
up going to send you a copy of ken's
book from paycheck to purpose i think
it'll be another tool in your tool belt
for encouragement along the way as you
find that new job let's also give him uh
austin a link to the get clear career
assessment so we give him some money
getting the whole kit and caboodle let's
do the package this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls
about money career life it's all here on
the ramsay show give us a call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five all right ken
last night yeah it was epic
live stream real estate reality check
with dave rachel and myself yeah right
out there in the lobby yeah it was
electric was it i didn't watch it
there were graphs they were tested
really it was all in oh dave doesn't
like the tesla's he's not a fan and he
was supposed by two tesla owners his by
his own data he said
that driving in a tesla there's a higher
chance of dying than skydiving
he made that up well he apparently he
said he pulled some data he said he he
did a google
and that many people die in tesla's
because they burn up on the streets i
think i bet you i know what he did i
think dave probably got creative
and he looked at some car accident you
know how often car accidents happen oh
yeah versus skydiving and he just went
okay well i'm gonna apply this to tesla
so in his mind it was technically
correct a little bit of a stretch but
you know he's dave yeah he's dave you
know he calls it a battery with four
wheels because it doesn't go vroom vroom
he doesn't think it's a real car yeah so
there we go i want to know if rachel has
gotten him in the car
i was wondering that as well
rachel and i for both driving you know
what i feel like guys if our youtube
guys i feel like the people want to see
dave riding shotgun with rachel or
george in the tesla uh the audience out
in the lobby is they want to see our
results
out there
uh so this is what the people want it'd
be a great youtube video well you know
all tesla jokes aside the event was
great and the good news is a lot of
people are reaching out to me saying hey
i couldn't watch it live the good news
is the replay is up so you can go to
radiosolutions.com
reality check watch the replay it's an
hour long and it's worth it it's very
encouraging there's a lot of a lot of
angry
frustrations i'm gonna go watch i'm not
in the real estate uh mode
but i want to watch it but i appreciate
that uh i wasn't able to watch it last
night because i was on the golf course
you'll have a good time i was trying to
wrap up nine holes there before the sun
set how'd it go yeah i hit the ball
pretty good hit the button
huh you hit par did i hit par is that
what they say folks i this is god love
him i've got so much training to do
folks he's such a bright charming guy
and he knows nothing about sport and i
don't judge him for that he talks a big
game but who did i beat in mini golf
again this is true i remind you all
right later in the program well we'll
tease this later in the hour there was a
time where george uh technically beat me
at mini golf uh so but and he holds it
over me there's no technicalities it was
a wash
all right let's move to that that
doesn't make sense that's what the
people are here for they're here for
they're here for wisdom i want to hear
how good i am at putt-putt they want to
hear life-changing calls
here we go
lindsay joins us in texarkana lindsay
welcome to the show
hi thank you all for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
um so my husband and i recently moved
and with our move we were able to sell
our home we made a pretty decent profit
on it and now we're currently renting in
our new city until we can find something
we want to buy and there's 50 acres that
recently came up for sale that we're
interested in and we're trying to decide
if we should buy in cash or if we should
finance it so that we have more money to
put down
as a down payment to build with what's
it cost to 50 acres
um
125 000 so 2500 an acre wow and how much
money do you have in cash
um
a little over 200 000. nice does that
include your emergency fund
no okay so outside of that you've got
200 to throw into this real estate deal
so if you paid cash for it you'd have 75
left over to start building
yes and how long would it take to build
and how much would it cost um
it's costing anywhere from like around
150 180 a square foot here
um
building would probably take
a year maybe a little bit less
okay so one year to build but you're not
sure the cost of it when we talking two
three hundred thousand four hundred
thousand
probably between three and four hundred
thousand okay
so you'd be taking i haven't gotten an
actual bid to build yet yeah well i
would pay cash for the acreage and then
try to cash flow as much as you can
along the journey and then whatever
mortgage you might have to take out
for the build
that's what i would do yeah how about 50
acres i mean is there more to this than
just having a plot to put a house on
because obviously that's a lot of
acreage
we'd like to farm it eventually there we
go okay there we go so this is the dream
is you want to run this 50-acre piece of
land farm it out live on it see that's
what i wanted to know george so lindsay
like when this thing popped when you
guys saw this i want to know what was
the reaction the conversation like
between you and the hubs
well we've been looking for acreage for
a while um and we found this place and
really liked it it seems like it
it's got good ground and it's not in a
low spot or anything which is what we've
we've ran into so far so you've done
your research pretty excited yeah that's
what i wanted to hear yeah see i i like
george's play here i you guys are really
excited i
i think george is right i jump on it if
you do all of the due diligence i mean
exhaust like i think you're very smart
person you guys are very savvy
i would do all the due diligence to make
sure that this thing again perks for
what you want it to perk for right to
based on the size house maybe eventual
expansion is it good soil to farm i
would do all the due diligence but i
because you guys were so excited about
even looking like and this is your
destination feels like to me
i would jump on it because even if you
had to live in a trailer on that land
for two years you know i'm not
suggesting you do that but i'm saying
like this is a uh you have the cash
to buy it outright
uh and a good chunk to put down
on building into george's point
now you'd have to get a construction
loan would you be able to do that
i think so
okay
yeah i would look into those pieces of
it so you don't get halfway through this
and go oh my gosh we're not gonna be
able to do this so i would get the
numbers on paper to take away all the
unknowns all the fear to where you go
okay we can afford this we're going to
do a 15-year fixed less than 25 percent
of our take-home pay with that strong
down payment we're going to pay cash for
this land i think it's a great plan
okay proud of you guys i appreciate it
it's awesome love to hear that george
and i want to come out and do a hunting
trip because you know george loves them
never done it never done it what are we
hunting pheasant what's out there oh i
like that you you pulled pheasant that
was a pretty good feel right and i'm
very impressed with that i don't know
what they got i know they got hogs yeah
well the wild hogs would be fun i don't
think you can hunt those sure oh sure
you can oh all right yeah and uh uh you
got deer of course which is great have
you ever had venison jordan's gonna
start naming every animal he can think
of no no i actually i i like that some
venison i've had jerky venison jerky
yeah venison is very lean very healthy
meat and uh but you got to get up early
george you got to get up early to get
the treats see they go yeah let's go
it's 4 a.m let's get out there i go no
way i'm sleeping in nothing is worth
this yeah anyways
uh ken i gotta mention
the jobs here at ramsey solutions a lot
of people hiring higher in hiring they
reach out to me and they go hey can you
get me a job they're trying to do
proximity principle but in a weird way
they'll just like send me a cold message
on linkedin that's not the right way to
do it i wanna work at ramsey can you
help me out yeah right
but i will say uh we talk a lot about
our mission over here to change
america's toxic money culture and it
makes us mad to see people get trapped
by debt and this whole toxic culture out
there with leadership with career and
we're on a mission to change lives and
if that's a passion that you share with
us you got to check out all the exciting
roles here at ramsay solutions we are
looking to fill a ton of them right now
there's never been a better time to find
a job doing work that matters and
specifically we need some great
developers some user experience
designers and writers to help us build
all these digital products that change
can i tell you a job that uh we're about
ready to post if we haven't posted it
tease it looking for an associate
producer of the ken coleman show whoa
screening calls uh
working on the show helping people so
like that's a broadcasting thing i'm
just telling you i don't know if it's
posted yet but it's coming yeah well if
you if that
suits your name about that go check
these out ramsaysolutions.com
careers you can also see what it's like
to work with us before you ever apply
you can follow us on instagram and
facebook by searching ramsay careers and
there's a lot people think oh well what
do they do around here we have literally
every position imaginable our team is
over a thousand people
from customer care to writers to
developers to creative folks to the
super nerdy folks the data analysts you
name it we got it so check it out if you
want to work with ken coleman and i
that's that is living the dream how
about well i don't know about that they
get to decide that but i know there is a
person that uh works on your uh wardrobe
that's true that's a high stress
position if you know george oh my
goodness the level of drama we went
through yesterday for wardrobe
unbelievable that's why they call me a
diva i love it well hey we got more of
your calls coming up triple eight eight
two five five two two five join us this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell next to me my friend ken
coleman we are taking your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
but we interrupt the scheduled
programming to bring to you a debt free
scream on the stage we've got dave and
holly how are you good how are you where
are you guys from
outside philadelphia one the city of
brotherly love oh ken's a big history
buff you can go all day about the
liberty bell don't get them started
so guys all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much debt did you
pay off yes sir we paid off 117
335 dollars wow in 28 months whoa
and what was your range of income during
that time we were right around 120 000.
awesome what do you guys do for a living
uh my primary profession is a teacher
teach health and phys at our local high
school and then also i work at our
church and also paint and power wash on
the side wow busy guy can i just say
quickly george that it's nice to see a
pe phys ed teacher that looks the part
yes that is true
i chuckled a little bit in my mind
because i went he actually looks the
part yeah
if i'm a senior or junior who's got a
bad attitude about push-ups i'm gonna
i'm gonna pay atten this guy looks like
he's done a few i could outrun all of my
pe teachers growing up so this guy i
could not have my p.e teachers growing
up couldn't get up the stairs were you
gonna say you can't fit in my skinny i
was i was just
hey george like one of your legs is bo
is all of george's gene combined all
right that's what's going on chicken
like coleman over here
well guys back to your story that's what
we're here for uh so what type of debt
was 117 000. before we say that my wife
is also a ministry coordinator at our
church oh no that's great you guys are
plugged in we are that's awesome you get
to work together in that capacity yeah
it's awesome that's cool yeah so our
debt was uh primarily student loans uh
we had 8 800 in our car and then the
rest was all student loans wow heavy on
the student loans whose degrees were
they
well mostly mine because i was a nurse
for 10 years before i quit and started
working for our church oh okay gotcha
cool okay so you guys decided 28 months
ago we're not gonna wait around for
forgiveness we're just gonna get rid of
this thing how did you get started on
this journey and plugged into us well um
the summer before in 2019 we
i'm a like saver and um he's more of a
free spirit in that aspect so he was
like let's build a paper patio and i was
like great let's do it do we have the
money and he was like yeah yeah we'll be
fine and i'm like okay great so we got
into the project and then we realized
maybe we weren't so fine um and that
just sent me into like a panic and then
in january our church offered financial
peace and i was like we were both like
we need to do something because one
month we would have way over what we
needed and then the next month we
wouldn't have like any like anywhere
near what we needed
so we started um in january of 2020
which was such a blessing because that
was right before the world shut down and
um if we wouldn't have done that we
would have totally panicked and not been
able to survive so wow that's awesome
without knowing it we were dave ish i
didn't believe in credit cards um i read
one of dave's books
long ago from a friend and i was like ah
that's good advice but you know
education loans like that's necessary
like a car loan that's necessary um and
then after taking those classes we were
like no this isn't necessary like we
know too much now there's such a better
way ignorance was bliss yes and then we
realized we're broke maybe we should
learn something yeah that's awesome so
proud of you guys so what was the
hardest part of this journey for you
i guess the hardest part was the last
the last push
we had several smaller loans that we got
that snowball rolling and it felt really
good
we had some money saved initially that
we were able to throw at it right away
and that kind of gave us like a jump
start but the last debt was like over 40
000. ouch and so even as we're rolling
our snowball into it we're like
this feels like it's gonna take forever
um and so that last push was hard
but it was also
fantastic we had like the little change
set up in our uh in our house so the
kids could help us cut off the chains
and we have like little prize chains
that we got every ten thousand we were
like okay here we're going to do a
little celebration and here we're gonna
do a little celebrate celebration to to
push through
wow wow so i want to i want to stay
where you are talking about how hard it
was you talk about the push if you
wouldn't mind i want you to share maybe
both of you what was specifically
like really specific what was so hard in
that last push was it was it uh maybe a
fear of missing out was it i mean i want
to know what the real challenge was
whether it was mental emotional well
what was tough for you guys in that last
push well i just think like when you're
building momentum you're excited you're
like yeah yeah and then it just seemed
so big and so like all of our friends
were like we're doing this and we're
like we paid off so much we're so close
and yet so far so our friends like um
always wanted us to do stuff we're like
sorry we're still working hard so yeah
um yeah and it was hard because
i mean the lord provided lots of
opportunities for us but like he was
working all the time so because i mean
he doesn't tell you he ought to coach
his wrestling and he was like picking up
side jobs he'd be like so what are we
doing this saturday and he'd say uh you
want to come paint and power wash with
me and so that's how we spend a lot of
our weekends and the kids came with us
so painting and power washing as a
family has become you know something so
cool yeah we say more is caught than
taught and i bet those kids saw some
really cool stuff with that kind of work
ethic and discipline and sacrifice that
sticks with them yeah absolutely i mean
we saw the lord's provision time and
time again and not in a um you know god
just gives you money but in a god
provided opportunities for us to work
and then he gave us the discipline to be
able to put it in the right place wow i
want to pause there ken this is
interesting the opportunity was not a
winning lottery ticket it was god
provided an opportunity for work yeah
that's interesting yeah a lot of people
don't see that he's working all the time
and not only is that hard physically
that gets to be hard mentally and
emotionally you don't see those cute
kiddos your beautiful wife and you start
going
goodness gracious and yet you keep
pressing on
what is that what is that and you've
just walked through it i want you to
tell people who feel right now they're
where you guys are they still have forty
thousand sixty thousand a hundred
thousand left they go we've paid off a
lot but it feels like we're never gonna
get to the top of the mountain i think
you can preach right now what kept you
going power washing painting never
seeing the wife and the kids
i mean dave says all the time that no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a
harvest of righteousness and that is so
true um that while in the moment it's
not pleasant
you know that what's on the other side
of that is totally worth it
i think this course and this this whole
program is so aptly named financial
peace
that you can experience peace outside of
finances even in in all of your life
when you know that together as a family
you're heading towards the same goal
yeah i think it's important too like we
changed their future and like our future
so like we took all like our parents
were always like yeah like debt is good
and it's okay to have debt you need a
credit score and we like
we're like now in this place where we
can say to our kids that's not where you
want to be like you can do this without
it and so we've been super blessed to be
able to you know change their lives and
that's like the motivator i love that
we'll bring them up on the stage what's
their names and ages
who do we got with us today
all right we have mara and she is five
and this is levi and he's seven cute i
love it and they're not scared of work
they've been seeing dad and mom hustle
on the weekends
and they love it guys we're so proud of
you thank you we've got a copy of dave's
number one book baby steps millionaires
that's your next chapter as you said
changing your family tree not just
financially but your character and
you've seen that and you've walked this
walk and we're so proud to have you guys
we also have a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to your
friends who are confused why you
couldn't go out and hang out with them
and eat out and you go this is why this
book changed our life on top of that
we're going to give you uh financial
peace university and every dollar all
part of ramsey plus for a whole year you
can give that away or go through it
again we just updated with some new
lessons maybe the kids can enjoy it too
yeah
all right before we do that can we just
give a shout out real quick to a couple
people um our friends that are with us
kaylee and ducky uh we have some folks
at home aaron and kelsey who walked
through us who walked through this with
us and then also keith and stacy who are
on the other side and encouraged us
saying it's good get there i love it
gotta have those cheerleaders yeah all
right let's get to it it's dave and
holly levi and mara from the
philadelphia area 117
355 dollars paid off in 28 months making
120 k
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
wow a lot of power from little mara and
levi
they practiced and they performed they
brought it because they were part of
this journey love that so beautiful
that's what this is all about guys if
you think you can't do it watch the show
listen to these stories these are
everyday people just like you who
decided things don't have to stay the
same and we believe you can do it too
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show it's a
show about you your life your money your
career everything that matters to you we
want to help i'm george campbell joined
today by ken coleman open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five zak joins us up next
in greensboro north carolina zack
welcome to the show
thank you
what's going on i'm 14.
i'm 14 and i'm calling because i started
a business five weeks ago cool i unload
the cars of vacationers this business
hold on a second hold on this is
fantastic uh describe this in a little
more detail
so what i do is i
put a post out on facebook
and
and i work with people to set up a time
for me to come over and unload their car
for them
when they get back from vacation
yes sir i did not know this was a
business opportunity
so what are you charging
uh 25 for a car and 35 for an suv or van
wow how many people have you got to do
this
i've done i've unloaded about 20 cars
and made almost a thousand dollars in
profit oh my goodness and is this
exclusively in your neighborhood or is
it kind of branching out in your in your
area
it branches out a bit but i'm staying
pretty close
i'm impressed so are these like elderly
people like why can't they unload their
own cars
just a convenience store a lot of people
a lot of people i work with are either
elderly or have had some medical surgery
oh okay that's what i was wondering like
ken coleman can unload his car he might
like like the convenience of someone
doing it for him ken coleman's got three
teenagers two or which are boys and i'll
tell you who's unloading the car and
they're doing it for free because i give
them food good for you zach so how can
we help today yeah
wow
i'm calling to ask if i should put this
into my car fund or if i should invest
any of it
oh
wow well my feelings on 14 year olds
investing are that you need to invest in
zach right now and you're doing a great
job of that starting your own business
this entrepreneurial journey so i would
put it towards your current goals
investing is a long term thing and
you've got plenty of time to do that and
i have a feeling you'll do very well in
that arena but right now i want you to
focus on the next four five six years of
what your future looks like so that
means getting a car paying cash for it a
reasonable used car being able to cash
flow any kind of education you get in
the future and then once you've got your
career set out whether that's after you
go to college or if you skip that and go
down the entrepreneurial path that's
what i would be doing so i would
definitely save that for a car yeah
absolutely zach i must ask because i
think a lot of adults could learn from
young zach i really do yeah so zach i'm
curious how you came up with the idea
because now that you've told me
specifically who your target audience is
that leads me to believe you heard about
the need or were you brainstorming hey i
wonder how i can make some money what
about people that are older what about
people have some medical issues and they
can't pick up their bags how did you
come on come up on this idea
so i heard about the need
and
where
where did you hear about the need
on on facebook my mom was actually
telling me about it because i'm not on
facebook right good for you yeah
and so she just read some stories some
posts where i mean tell me a little bit
more
she saw a post on a on a group
basically asking
if they they had this service
wow and so when she mentioned it to you
like how quickly you go i'm gonna try
that did you did you kick it around a
little bit well what happened
i kicked it around a little bit but
i i'd been looking for a job and i i
always
had loved the idea of starting my own
business so
when i heard about the idea it was a
pretty easy decision yeah i love it okay
i want to add one little very mature 14
year old
it is he's not out there are you playing
video game zach are you enjoying your
childhood
yes sir i'm definitely enjoying my
childhood yeah he doesn't strike me as
somebody like you that was a shut-in you
know what i mean he's got a life george
uh but but zach let me ask you this
you've always wanted to own your own
business so i want to add
george's advice was great advice was
great but but i would be saving every
penny besides some fun stuff
and um uh the car so like just to be 14
year old zach you got some spending
money and then everything else in the
car uh but then when i s once i stayed
up for the car i would be putting every
penny
besides just fun stuff for zach into the
future zach inc and what i mean is that
i think the more you do this and you
work for yourself and you help people
out i think ideas are gonna formulate
or you're going to realize wait a second
i can do very well at this and get
myself to a position where i can be a
teen entrepreneur
by doing multiple business starts while
you're still in high school so i love
you saving saving saving to give you
options because i just think you're that
kind of kid yeah but it sounds like you
know what's next and then that's your
next goal is saving up to pay cash for
that car
yes sir call us back let us know what it
is yeah i want to follow your journey
zack yeah that's awesome man good for
you this gives me a lot of hope for the
next generation ken listen i i you know
listen i'm the resident uh i'm the
resident gen xer here on the show today
and you have teenagers i have teenagers
um i get a little upset when when people
of my generation uh or boomers
you know uh just kind of randomly paint
younger generations with a broad brush
they did it a lot with millennials your
generation they go they don't like to
work i think that's garbage you're an
example you're one of the hardest
workers i know your path to being a
ramsey personality was was one of
perseverance and and hard work and i
just think that you know you look at
these 14 year olds
and we shouldn't be so shocked
because character is in every generation
um
and uh he's got character he's got he's
got some gumption uh he's got a vision
yeah for the future and we shouldn't be
so shocked you know and uh paint people
with a broad brush so i love it very
interesting stuff thanks for the call
zach appreciate it gabby joins us up
next in orlando gabby welcome to the
show
hi uh thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help today
so my husband and i are on baby steps
four five and six and we're super
excited and we're focused
um we have looked into the smart buster
pros and we have interviewed five of
them and have narrowed it down to two
wow um they're both giving yeah they're
both giving very similar advice that
alliance is what they would recommend
um we really like them both and so
i'm having a heart and they both also
have the heart of a teacher so i'm just
having a hard time you know picking
which one would be best for
our you know retirement and future and i
just didn't know if you guys could help
us
make that final decision
sure we've asked i mean we've got a
great uh resource online on our website
about you know interviewing the
financial advisors but at this point
they're going to give you the same
advice probably put you in about the
same funds
and so it really comes down to you know
what's the expense ratios what are the
fees who do we want to go with long term
i i have a question gabby
do you have a choice and does your
husband have a different choice are you
both
presenting as we're torn i gotta know
come on gaby tell me
yes
my husband is kind of has the mindset
where if whatever i feel like i'm i'm
more
whatever person i feel is best he thinks
as well okay so so let's put you on very
hard no it's really easy so you're the
one that called gabby
and feels like you're the most heavy
vote in the house uh your husband is by
the way this is a smart husband george
oh yeah happy wife happy life your
husband's no idiot gabby um so he's he's
kind of put it in your boat i think
you're leaning towards one or the other
and i want you to for a moment suspend
all of the technical knowledge
uh heart of the teacher all that i just
want you to think about your personal
connection when you sat with both can
you do that run it through your head
right now you doing it
okay all right which one do you just
seem to like a little bit more
personal connection nope you already
selected when i asked you a question you
selected one didn't you gabby
i
yeah the one i'm leaning towards is
giving me like the most advice and
explaining it really well but the other
one
seems to be
more like kind of like an ant type
relationship there it is um now let me
ask a question gavin i don't mind being
wrong you can you can you can you can
tell me if i'm wrong on the air when i
ask you the question your brain selected
the ant type figure true or false
[Music]
it did but i feel like this is
underneath there no it's not the wrong
answer it's not the wrong answer there's
not the wrong answer here's why
the other one gave good information so
does the ant like but the ant is the
personal connection and that's the key i
think between this situation tough
choice
go with the trust and the connection
follow your heart gabby there it is that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsey shop
can be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero in your story
[Music]
from the ramsay network this is the
ramsay show where we help you get
control of your money get ahead in your
career and get on the path to living
well i'm george campbell joined today by
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show you guessed it ken coleman
and we are here to take your call
america on your money your life whatever
you're grappling with career changes we
would love to help so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five molly is kicking us off in phoenix
arizona molly welcome to the show
there there's mom george how are you
doing today so great we're happy to take
your call what's going on
so essentially the question is what is
more important
what you do
or where you live
oh
what has brought you to this crossroads
molly
so i currently live in phoenix arizona i
went to school here and i work with
air permitting consulting so
a good portion of that is
date specific
um so my experience
in
my job is faith-specific and i've only
been with my firm for a year and a half
so you're supposed to do that whole
three to five years thing
um however
my sister is pregnant in north carolina
um and
if all
if i wasn't worried about how would this
look on my resume
um
does my job experience apply
i'd be in north carolina right now
okay i understand that right now but
what happens when the baby comes is that
is this like i want to be near my sister
as long as she has a child play that out
a little bit more because that's a
strong statement
so
it is just the the two of us so i've got
the one sister and then her husband is
also a single child so it's a small
family and
the parents
aren't really in the picture so i want
to be there to to help out and to
be involved in
my niece or nephew's lives
okay um um i understand that so you're
saying you're the the your niece and
nephew their parents aren't involved
they're not there are you talking about
the grandparents
potential grandparents yes sorry
okay she hasn't figured out if it's a
girl or boy in it
so the struggle is i want to move to
north carolina but my career field
doesn't exist there
the career feeling field exists but i'd
be essentially starting from scratch as
no you're not experiencing this field no
you just said you've been there a year
and a half
yeah there's no golden rule that says
you have to do it for three years to get
a job
lots of regulations are specific so i'm
worried that if i just up and go to
north carolina that i
will be starting my learning curve over
okay so do you know this for a fact have
you looked up the north carolina
regulations in the field that you're in
yes and so it's
the federal regulations are of course
the same but
arizona and north carolina have
different stances on
um environmental regulations right due
solely to the environment right but what
i'm saying is
are you in any way disqualified
from being able to do what you do now in
arizona doing that in north carolina are
you un are you not experienced enough is
there some sort of state regulation that
makes it very hard for you to step from
phoenix to north carolina and do the
work you want to do
no okay then so you've concocted a
monster under the bed and there's no
monster there
there's a monster and there's no harm in
exploring and interviewing and going hey
let me see if there's a job out there in
north carolina that'll take me yeah like
make it my full-time hobby to when
you're not working sleeping eating
hanging with friends and family you are
looking and trying to interview and get
an offer in north carolina
because you don't have to marry these
companies if they make you an offer but
you got to dig you got to look for
opportunities and here's the other thing
i would not limit yourself to that
industry unless you're saying that is
your dream industry
okay so
to look into north carolina for a job
and then once i have one movement yeah
absolutely unless well sure your fear is
you're not going to be able to get a job
there right
yes yeah but that's nonsense this is the
hottest job market
that we've ever seen in the united
states molly can i give you some some
data real quick to help to help kind of
assure you we are at 3.6 unemployment
right now
and i give you a real picture of this as
we look across the nation
we have about 11.3 million 11.4 million
jobs available in the united states
right now and about
8.6 8.7 million people unemployed those
numbers change month to month but it's
about that
and so that's why we're seeing what they
call this this crazy job market where
companies can't find people so all of a
sudden molly you are a very talented
woman true or false
yeah well that didn't change that that
wasn't a question mark we needed to work
on that for the old interview all right
i'm going to ask you that again i want
you to say that with some
ken is the interviewer yeah molly you're
a very talented woman correct
correct there we go that's gonna play
well all right now listen here's the
point
you have talent you have experience to
offer i also saw george uh headline
yesterday because i am a as you know an
avid news reader
and molly the state of north carolina
is the healthiest state economy in the
united states the most business friendly
state that's what was reported they've
got a lot going on in north carolina it
is a super super attractive job market
you have the benefit of having friends
and family in that area of north
carolina where you would like to be so
you are not starting from scratch with
connections true or false
true there we go so we look
and we get opportunities offered to us
we decide is it the right opportunity
but there's no risk here
uh the riskiest thing you could do is if
you were to move there sight unseen with
no job and live with your sister because
you guys get along so great and that
would be a safe landing route but even
that's not risky
so start looking
and molly let's play out the worst case
scenario worst case let's say the
regulation is you got to be there three
years so that's a year and a half away
which means your niece or nephew at that
point is a year old or so which means
you step into their life full time
locally from one year old until the rest
of their life that's the worst case
scenario
correct yeah that doesn't sound so bad
yeah so either way you're fine but i i
know your heart is to be with family and
so i'm gonna be about the business of
doing everything i can do to get to
north carolina as soon as possible but
we're gonna bring the boat close to the
dock and have the job before we step so
molly back to your original question
when you opened up the conversation
what's more important what i'm doing or
where i live and you've created a false
choice
you can live where you want to live and
do what you want to do ding ding ding
tell her what she's won george you've
won a prize of living your best life oh
very very good there it is ken but this
there's a lot that's a false choice yeah
the heart behind it is important for
people to realize a lot of people out
there there's a lot of doubt right now
people don't believe that they can have
it all that they can do what they want
to do get paid well to do it live where
they want to live and the numbers the
data shows us otherwise it's a
hot job market a lot of talented folks
out there now's the time if you want to
make a jump but do it wisely george you
model this people don't know you wanted
to be in nashville you wanted to work
for ramsey solutions you figured out a
way to do it you did the hard work you
worked your way up and today here you
sit next to the camera and a dream denim
jacket that you always wanted to wear
never dreamed i'd be wearing denim next
to ken coleman but here we are that's
true nobody's dreaming of that actually
i love it more of the show coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell
joined by ken coleman today you know
there's so much crazy stuff going on and
people are looking for direction on how
to handle their finances day to day but
they're also struggling to see how it's
even possible to build wealth
so at our building wealth live event we
walk you through all the crazy and teach
you the steps to build real lasting
wealth and the principles we teach here
are the only principles that work in
prosperous times and in hard times and
no matter where you are with your money
today you can get on a path to building
wealth we're going to show you how the
building wealth live tour has already
made a couple of great stops in vegas
and orlando wrapping up our spring
portion but we're just getting started
we've got a bunch of cities this fall
phoenix on september 13th we are almost
sold out in phoenix so go ahead and grab
your tickets there sacramento on
november 1st almost sold out there as
well
headed to minneapolis on november 10th
and then we are rounding it out in
beautiful san antonio on november 15th
so please join us if you're near those
areas if you can get there it's a great
time dave ramsey rachel cruz ken coleman
dr john deloney and myself we'll all be
there it'll be a party can't wait to see
you guys event passes start at just 25
bucks or you can get a four pack of
passes starting at 60
so bring your friends we're gonna have a
good time ramsay solutions.com events is
the place to reserve your seats now and
ken fun fact not only do we do the event
but there's like a pre-show with you and
deloney where you guys have a special
segment you take questions it's powerful
we talk about the
natural tension between your
professional obligations and your
relationship responsibilities right
there's a tension between you know what
i'm going for it or maybe we have two
working
uh people in the house in the marriage
what's that like so we talk about
relationships and work
and the the tension on both sides of
those things and so we just talk uh
really for only about five ten minutes
john and i and then we take questions
the entire time it's just like a
free-for-all
and uh it's been a lot of fun that's
where some of the magic happens yeah
those q and a portions yeah boy i'll
tell you what i'm really excited about
these cities um great cities phoenix is
crazy uh the the response there is so
hot and uh no pun intended and uh boy
but i'm a little nervous about
minneapolis in november oh yeah could be
dangerous uh well i want you to pack
your turtleneck
uh i think that's probably
turtlenecks no i don't wanna catch you
no you signed up for this
well it's a lot of fun we i'm so glad
we're back on the road ken i missed it
yeah it's the crowds have been amazing
so there's something special that
happens in community we know this as
humans uh whether it be at a church or
like an fpu class but will you get in a
big uh arena or a big venue like some of
these places we're in it's electric and
uh so we'd love to see you there yeah
ramsay solutions dot com slash events
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five anthony joins
us up next in seattle anthony welcome to
the show
hello hey guys thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help today
yeah so
i'm like i'm 20 years old and i go to
college
i've been very lucky with my parents and
i've i've worked throughout my school
pretty much in high school and through
college and i want to make sure i'm on
the right path
because i want to
put i want to put down a down payment
for a house and i just wanted to see
if i could afford it or if i should
maybe move to a lower cost of living
area
or if i'm just rushing
you're still in college right now
yeah i graduate next spring
wow okay congratulations what
professional path are you planning to
head on
yeah um operations management so lean
pretty much
okay what was that operations
management yeah like lean um continuous
improvement oh gotcha gotcha yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so you can
do that pretty much anywhere in the
country do you have your your site set
on a certain place
or do you want to stay in seattle um
yeah
i i'm yeah so i would like to stay
around this area um i have family and a
girlfriend in this area so i would
prefer it okay but you're saying should
i move to somewhere more affordable
uh even though i don't really want to
leave just because you've got your
sights set on being a homeowner
yeah because i i really want to be able
to afford it i don't want to get into a
bad situation what are you thinking
about buying what does a ford mean what
kind of house what size what price range
are we looking at
yeah so either a condo or a house um
probably like two bedrooms
uh around here i found that a good condo
decent condos like 275
um and then a house is like for two to
three bedrooms is around five hundred
thousand yeah well that's let me tell
you something as a single guy graduating
i know you got a girlfriend but that's
just too much house
that's just too much george
i in my two dad right now no i think as
a i think he's uh an excited 20 year old
you're very driven you're gonna get
there but i think we pumped the brakes
on this right now let's graduate let's
see what kind of job we get what kind of
money we make how much money we can save
up and you can begin making you can
pre-decide that i'm gonna save up every
penny i'm gonna avoid debt because
that's gonna set you up to be a
homeowner much faster so i think right
now it's cool that you're looking have
that goal in the back of your mind i
would aim for that lowest common
denominator maybe we go for the condo at
275. and we know a few years from now
it's going to appreciate a little bit so
let's start saving up that down payment
as we get out of college but you're not
working right now are you are you
working while in school
i am yeah so i have um
i have i've been saving up pretty much a
lot so my parents have actually given me
um started up a roth ira it's 14 500 in
it currently
i also have 13 000 a little over 13 000
in investments uh s p 500
just in a taxable account outside of
retirement
yes outside of retirement okay and then
my father's actually said my father and
my mom have said that they were going to
give me 20 000 when i graduate
which is very that's nice just as a gift
okay so that puts you at like 33k of
cash once you cash out of that
investment fund
and then how much can we save up on top
of that in the next few years
maybe another 40 000
yeah and
my estimated income
ranges from like like starting income
would be somewhere from like 65 and 75
from what i've heard from other people
in this major
cool i'm curious anthony do you feel uh
pressure from someone
or have you created a little bit of
pressure on yourself because you're so
frugal and seems like you're very very
knowledgeable
uh about money and you and you're very
serious about you know being a very
stewardess person
i'm just curious where's this coming
from this pressure to buy a house so
quickly
i think it's more of like what i want
i've i've always wanted to kind of own a
house and kind of be independent
um
and you can be independent without being
a homeowner i mean couldn't you rent
somewhere on your own
yeah yeah i definitely can i just
don't want to throw that money away and
rent you know i i knew we were getting
there george why is renting not throwing
money away well you're buying yourself
patience there's a rent has a terrible
stigma these days i don't know what it
is about it because i could be putting
that money towards an asset i could own
an asset but the truth i looked in the
constitution the other day ken nowhere
in there does it say you get to be a
homeowner as an american right you know
george that's a very astute point there
i know you're a constitutionalist it's
not there you're right the right to own
a home is nowhere in the bill of rights
and we're big fans of being a homeowner
it's a big huge part of building it
several times but there's no reason to
be to be so gung-ho about that at 20. i
think you're going to get there because
of how driven you are naturally but i
would focus right now on what's the
right thing for me right now and the
truth is if you get married one day
your future wife is going to go this
ain't it and she's going to want to move
somewhere else so i'm ok with you
loading up a giant pile of cash and when
you're financially ready you can do a
15-year fixed quarter of your take-home
pay then i would go all right anthony's
ready to do it but right now focus on
your career focus on what kind of income
you're going to have and then make those
kinds of decisions yeah anthony george
is absolutely right i want to give you
one little mind a little thought maybe a
mental shift for you okay over the next
couple years if you do what george said
i don't want you to be thinking about
how much money you're throwing away in
the form of rent i want you to think
about how renting
is allowing you to save and giving you
better options because you're piling up
a bigger amount of money i want you to
flip the script there when the toilet
breaks it's not your problem oh it's
wonderful there's a lot of benefits to
renting i know rents sky high and
seattle's crazy but man you could rent
for a year or two as you save up and get
established in your career and you start
making more money
but if you keep living the way you're
living you're going to be a homeowner
way sooner than most americans so we're
proud of you man stay the course you got
this this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsey show you
probably knew that but a reminder for
you there i'm george campbell joined by
ken coleman today and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five so ken i i've been posting
these instagram reels i know you post
them as well yeah and you're doing a
great job by the way thank you uh it's
what i come to expect from you uh pithy
and practical well i love um i speak in
tweets you know it's very it's like
proverbs
mad respect
do you speak in tweets i just i'm i'm
quick with it i don't have a lot to say
and i get to it yeah yeah and so i
posted one earlier uh it was a southwest
hack you know what i mean i love money
hacks i'm a frugal people i love to save
a dime and i've been here's the shocking
part let me hear it people are
commenting saying i just saved 128
dollars thanks to your hack i just got
62 dollars back for a flight i just
saved 41
i just got 20 000 sellers right already
i'd like to hear the heck i'd like to
save a buck or two and that's what we
call a t-scan you're gonna have to go
look for it ah i gotta go to your
you gotta go to my gram at george
campbell with a k k-a-m-e-l what do i
gotta do and my wife here's the funny
part and he doesn't even know about it i
did the hack myself and i got
50-something dollars back and i never
told her so she's commenting on my
instagram video going wow thanks for
letting us know but i saved her money i
didn't spend it there's the big
difference and i need to know did you
come up with this hack or did you borrow
it and then share i think i may have
stumbled upon it is this it right here
yes so you can basically it's your
latest post at george campbell that's
camel with a k uh
and uh oh look at you george you're
starting to really uh get the old
followers give george a follow i
appreciate it you like savings
but really i love i just love helping
people because here's the thing ken yes
you might save a buck in this case it's
a lot more than a buck but what i love
is it gives people
uh
the encouragement that they can take
control their money and they start
getting creative and going where else
can i start saving some money and all
that adds up while you're while you're
yammering on i'm reading your post and i
don't want to give it away but are you
telling me i've got a flight
uh with my daughter and i josie you're
going to my niece's wedding in august
yep i need to do what you just suggested
yes and you think is it a guarantee that
it's gonna work no guarantees in this
life how do you know what i do is i
check my flights that i've already
booked because a lot of people right now
their book and travel plans and it's
real expensive right now and so they're
worried i'm gonna book a flight and it's
not the right time i paid too much for
my flight what if it goes down so the
hack is to go back and check to see if
you can make money save money get money
back for a flight you've already booked
on southwest by rebooking it by
rebooking the same flight exactly and so
but you you can see if you're gonna say
before you click exactly and so i walk
through exactly how to do that there you
go well guess what we're doing over
appetizers tonight that's right uh by
the way big news james uh the colemans
and the camels going to dinner tonight
after the show can people often wonder
are they
friends do we hang out off-site people
don't wonder nobody cares but i told you
anyway and tonight over appetizers
i'll tell you what i'm gonna pick up the
appetizer
if you'll help me see if i could save
money
uh on my flight that feels like a nice
trade don't threaten me with a good time
oh my goodness listen well here's the
thing can i go so go check it out are
you sending people to instagram yeah
yeah at georgetown it's actually right
there in this post i'm very excited it's
my first reel right there so uh i
thought man i'm hanging out with ken for
three hours it's not enough three whoa i
didn't commit to three well that's the
show the rambling i thought we talked
about dinner tonight this is awkward and
it's just not enough and so i thought
let's get dinner tonight after the show
and we're doing it yeah looking forward
to it yeah well whitney's lovely and
stacy they're they love you they get
along and so george george and i largely
ignore each other uh we're just there to
foot the bill the 100
yeah
i love it well we're taking your calls
about life money career you name it and
mark joins us up next in buffalo mark
welcome to the show
hey you guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can ken and i help
um so
i'm 22 years old i still live with my
parents um i work a full-time job i make
about 52 000 a year right now
i'm about to start an online college
program just to further my education and
my career which i'm going to be paying
for out of pocket
i just bought a new old car
something
more reliable than my last so my next
like big purchase that's going to be
coming up is obviously going to be a
house um
and so you know i've been looking and
i've talked to like a realtor and my
question is i have a
a decent amount in savings but
i also started a individual investment
account back in february of 2021.
so
obviously it was boogiein for a while
and you know
it is in the grain but now not so much
anymore and i'm wondering
if potentially i made a mistake i
haven't lost a ton of money it's it's
mostly just vanguard etfs well you
haven't lost anything until you sell
those shares
well that's what i'm saying and so do i
think it's better to or do you guys
think it's better to
get out of that and add that money to my
savings to keep saving for a down
payment or so my accounts i have uh in
just normal savings accounts i have
about 44 000
and then in my 401k through work i have
about a little over 3 000
and then in my investment account i
i put
about
20
300 in
and it's currently at about like 18 000
so
it's in the negative and my mentality is
yeah i don't lose until i sell it but is
it like would it be more wise to to take
it out and add it to my savings since my
next big purchase is gonna be a house
eventually even though i i don't need to
buy it immediately i have a good
situation with my family but i am 22 and
you know
i'm blessed to be able to live with them
for now and we have a good relationship
so they're not kicking me out or
anything but if i can stay here until i
can save up to buy one rather than you
know just try and get my way out and
start renting first how much do you guys
just wait typing
no doubt no debt at all and you've got
44 000 in liquid savings you got 18 000
sitting in the non-retirement investment
account
yep so i would start to look at what an
exit strategy looks like for mom and dad
and by then that investment account will
probably have come back i feel good
about the us economy in the next year or
two climbing out of this uh hole we've
we've had and i think at that point
you're gonna have a big pile of cash
won't you probably close to i mean if
you're living at home with no expenses
you can put away most of your paycheck
yeah i've been you know diligently
saving for a couple years now but since
i got um the job i'm working at now
um back in november
uh i mean i track everything i'm saving
on average about like 13 to 1600 a month
that's great
so you're talking you know 15 20 000 a
year you could save
yeah
this year alone the first six months i
have already saved 13 000
i love it so let's say you can save 20
grand in the next year because you're
hustling maybe you take on a side job
you got 44 000 savings that's 64. and
let's say that investment account comes
back to what you put in that's another
20. so that's 84 000 you have as a down
payment now we've got to set aside an
emergency fund which sounds like we've
got to set aside may 15 of that right
yeah so let's call it 70 000 a year from
now and then i would go and look all
right what can that get me
in my area that i want to live in
buffalo new york that i can put 70 000
down and on a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage have the payment be no more
than a quarter of my take-home pay
so that would be my next homework
assignment for you
right well i
i've been thinking about it for a while
now um and i had been waiting to like
really get into it until i got a more
reliable like car
um but i i just purchased one a month
ago and actually with the sale on my
motorcycle my old car i came out in that
positive right um for the new car which
is nice um
so it just depends on like the area i
want to live in um
but
because if i stay where my direct family
is um in this small city we live north
of buffalo
i mean houses are affordable and i could
probably get like a
a thousand square foot house for
like
150 but where i want to live closer to
the city it's probably going to be more
expensive
and i i don't know because now i'm
hearing that there's going to be another
75 point basis hike well don't believe
everything you hear and even with the
interest rates you can always refinance
later on so i don't want you to focus on
that focus on what you can afford based
on those parameters that way you're not
looking at emotion you're looking at
facts and the facts are when it's less
than a quarter of your take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed you have margin you can
breathe no matter what's going on the
economy you've got wiggle room that's
what that's all about and don't settle
don't settle for a house just because
well i can afford it now be patient and
if you rent for a year it's okay yeah
nothing wrong with that man but keep
living debt-free keep saving you're
going to get there mark appreciate the
call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined by ken
coleman this is the ramsey show it's a
free call triple eight 825-5225
joins us up next in beautiful
chattanooga tennessee richard welcome to
the show
thank you so much fellas uh enjoy dinner
tonight nashville's got a ton of great
great restaurants thank you richard and
thank you richard george is showing me
one of his favorite haunts in his neck
of the woods so i'm on george's home
turf yeah it's very exciting
i know how can we help today
i just need you to hold my hand through
this i've got a very athletic daughter
who
is going to go to school next year
doesn't get a lot of money for athletics
but
we got the tally
this week that's going to be
after an academic scholarship of 15 plus
thousand it's going to be
38 000 bucks a year
and we
we have sacrificed and paid cash for
them for private schools here
in town and still have one
in high school for another three years
and she can go to our in-state school
um
and we can
it's a wash we can we can pay cash for
it but she wants to fulfill her quote
dream what's wrong with the in-state
school in her mind
oh she loves it it was her first love
but the coach did not reach out to her
and
and oh she can't do athletics there
no she can she could walk on
but
this was the one the place she wants to
go is the one place where the coach
showed her some love and responded and
reached out
and it's not a big sport it's track and
field so
she gets a book stipend and a little bit
of help but at the end of the day she
can go to her in-state school i'm a
georgia resident even though i live in
chattanooga right outside of town
and she can get the biggest scholarship
because of her a.c.t and and and ap
courses and we can pay for it in cash
and she can try to walk on but i don't
have the support of
her or
my wife because my wife
fulfill her dream and whatever it takes
to fulfill her dream
and we're debt-free except for our house
and
we're not going to take on additional
debt and student loans right so you've
made this clear
yes i have
i have and
my daughter says she's going to do it on
her own
and
she wants to pursue
and i told her the anchor and the new
surround her neck for 20 or 30 years
after she already gets out of school
that she's still going to be paying on
this
and she's willing to pay 152 000
go into debt for that because a coach
showed her some love
um
that's what i'm hearing
what's the uh
what's the uh academic direction does
she express maybe uh the major or the
career field
that she wants to go into being
yeah she wants to be in sports medicine
you know orthopedics and or
uh
rehabilitation physical therapy oh she's
a good athlete yeah so here's athlete
but it's it's not like she's playing
football for this university and getting
a full ride 100
so so uh so richard uh i've got three
kids so i know exactly
the dilemma you're in when you tell kids
this doesn't make any sense and they
don't hear a word you're saying it's
like the teacher on charlie brown wow
wow that's all your white your
daughter's hearing and your wife's not
helping out which is that is just brutal
however
the only chance i think
uh that you have to uh persuade her
because this is what this boils down to
this is a persuasion
he can't force her she can go out and
get the loans in her name unfortunately
and they the these these student loans
these predatory companies the federal
government they don't give a crap about
these kids right uh so she can do it
whether you want it or not so now this
is persuasion game so here's what i
think you got to do
i think you got to show her real numbers
i don't think you
level-headed
uh sweet kind posture none of that's
going to get her attention you've
already tried that so i think what you
have to do is george you know gave you
the number so you write down 150 000
plus on paper okay
and then you go do the research and show
her what uh
range of salary could be in the first
three to five years in any one of those
three fields you just listed out to me
right
go do your homework all that's readily
available
and then run the numbers you can go find
this out but run the numbers on what her
student loan payment on that kind of
money is going to be per month and just
show her how long it would take to pay
it off plus what she would be paying in
minimums without making any dent you
know what i'm saying just like literally
take all reason and emotion out of it
and just go hey i i don't want to be
obnoxious and annoying dad
but do you trust me enough to look at
these numbers and i want you to know
i've went and i've done the research i
want to show you
what this is going to mean to you
the minute you get out of school and you
have to pay these back i think you got
to show her the numbers and let her soak
on that let her chew on that and then
show her the option of going to the
state school
and then show her how little money she
would have to pay and you just literally
paint a picture for her that is just as
straightforward as she could possibly
see and see you would have to work this
amount of years to pay off this much
this year i mean show her that whole
narrative and there's a false narrative
that if i go to this school with this
coach it's going to get me closer to my
dream but the truth is it's going to
make her further away than ever because
when she gets out of school
every bit of her income has got a name
on it sally may yeah and richard this
doesn't include if she wants to go
sports medicine to a doctor level or to
a therapist level where she's gonna have
to get additional training
correct so reminder of what her goals
are to be in sports medicine as a career
not to be a track and field star for the
rest of her life so let's make that a
very small part of the equation and the
bigger part how can we do this debt free
so that you can do sports medicine
wherever you want to do get paid
whatever you want to get paid and not
have to worry about payments because
right now i'm looking at 1600 bucks in
payments 50 grand in interest as soon as
she graduates
and i want to go also i'm going to lay
out our budget what we do every month
and show her what the increase would be
if we paid cash for this and then put a
cap on it and say
this is what i can we can pay other than
that
you're on your own and do the tough love
but we're not gonna eat rice and beans
beans and rice no she can eat she can
eat beans and rice
exactly and you want to help her avoid
the stupid tax here because you love her
dearly but the truth is she's her own
person if she wants to go down that road
like ken said you can't stop her but
what you can do is sit down with her as
a loving dad and not to nag her but
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
send you a link to borrow the future of
the documentary we're going to pay for
it so hang on the line austin will pick
up we'll get you a code to watch that
maybe you go on a daddy-daughter date
and that includes watching the bard
future documentary it's 88 minutes and i
promise you it will cause her to start
asking questions yeah may not change her
mind overnight but she may go hold on
dad did i you hear that story of the guy
that orthodontist who in a million
dollars into debt
and so i think that will help at least
start a new conversation yeah
do you want and i really appreciate that
you all uh one quick question and i
didn't call for that but i appreciate
that um
if nothing else can
if i can't convince her and i'm still
fighting uphill battle with mama and her
do i let her just
take it on for one year
and just sit back and just let her see
firsthand what it's gonna well she won't
see anything because she won't have to
pay a dime until six months after she
graduates so she has no concept of what
this payment feels like when you have a
starter salary in sports medicine and
show her that show her what a starter
salary in sports medicine show her what
the taxes will be what her net will be
how much of her income the student loan
payment will be and then show her what
kind of life she's going to have richard
i i want to go back to two things we
said earlier to remind you to answer
that question number one you can't
control it she can go do it if she wants
to do it and it sucks
but you
there's no letting her do anything
secondly
before you sit down with your daughter
and show her those numbers that exercise
i laid out you need to show that to your
wife
and i think you i think this is the
nuclear card you look at your wife and
go babe i'm i'm i'm pleading for you to
support me on this and help us try to
persuade our daughter
you need to look at these numbers do you
really want her to do this i'd go that
direction too well and at this point he
just looks like the bad guy because mom
and daughter are going oh gosh what a
fuddy duddy he doesn't really have my
dream the dream will become a nightmare
we've seen it time and time again with
this student loan crisis guys avoided at
all costs it's a plague that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to my co-host ken coleman all the
folks in the booth keeping the show
afloat and to you america we appreciate
you listening we'll be back with you
before you know
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls
about work life money relationships
career
switching jobs switching homes you name
it we are here for you triple eight
eight two five five two two five joe
kicks us off this hour he's in
pittsburgh pennsylvania joe welcome to
the show i think let's see if i can get
to him are you there
yep can you hear me yes how you doing
today how can we help
i'm doing great thank you for having me
um i i give a financial question i've
reached recently got married
and
you know the my situation has been it's
a little more complex
with my wife's
situation now and i just wanted uh your
direction on uh what we might do about
it okay lay out the picture for us so
she has a substantial amount of student
loan debt and she paid off 30 000 last
year and she has about 150 left
i don't have any that other than my
truck
she's a car note
and i own
two multi-unit rental properties
and i'm contemplating selling the one in
order to get rid of the um
you know the student loan debt okay but
they're my babies and i'm
just calling you for uh
some advice on it all right so you got
married and you're sitting there with
what's the total debt outside of the
rental properties the two car loans plus
the 150k what does that add up to
it's right around 200 000. 200 000. and
what is your household income total
between you and your wife
it is a little over 200 okay we got a
big shovel
so we've got the pile of debt there but
we can clean this up fairly quickly what
could you sell one of the rentals for
which one do you like the least and what
could you sell it for and what would you
net
um
i could sell
sell the one and make around
70 on it
okay so you'd make 70 net on one of them
and what would you put that towards
knock out the car loans
um well sure she's a couple private
loans that are good and this is why i
want to do this is because the interest
rates are kind of crazy on them what
seems like over 10
over 10 crazy ouch
and what's the other rental worth if you
sold that one
um that is the one we're actually living
in that's
probably got about you know 40 000 of
equity
okay after commissions and everything
and that's your primary residence right
now so we got it we're hanging on to
that one obviously
and what are the cars worth
um she has a it's a brand new um prius
um so it's probably worth what she has
into it um and my trucks basically work
worth about what i have into it throw on
it i should say
okay so what could let's say you sold
both cars
it'd be a wash you'd get rid of the debt
get rid of about 50 000.
yeah how much money do you have in
savings just in liquid cash between you
guys
um we really don't have um
anything i just put some money into one
of the rentals so that was all of our
cash so you got nothing in the bank
right now we have you know a couple
grand okay
well i mean uh i'm selling the rental if
i'm you because this is a if you want to
not make this a slog because right now
how much money could you even put
towards the debt every month or every
year
i mean well like i said with her income
alone she put 30 000 towards it so you
could do another 30.
and we paid for a wedding as well
so so at this point this is a you know a
five-year journey if you were putting
60k
maybe
40 50k a year i mean this is a long time
so i want to speed this up to where you
can do this in two years
and that means making some sacrifices
which means i'm probably i'm definitely
selling the rental i might look at
selling the cars well let's walk through
that so he makes seventy thousand we
hope or maybe a little less realtors
realtor fees there
so then where where does he put the
where would you have i'm going to list
these debts out smallest to largest i
know you've got the high interest rate
student loans but i think the progress
that you're going to feel freeing up
those payments as you knock out those
small debts that's going to give you the
the boost you need to make it through
this journey yeah but george i want to
get specific for a second can i can i do
that you're the expert you like let's
get nerdy ken all right so so he sells
the rental
uh and joe give us a round number what
do you think you actually walk away with
after the realtor fees and everything
what's in your pocket once you sell that
reel that uh that house
that's
realistically between you know 60 and
70. okay so let's let's split the
difference a65 all right you got the two
cars that's an ignore what are your car
payments a month between those two new
cars or roughly new cars it's
right around a thousand a month oh baby
so george so if you sold the cars today
you just freed up a thousand a month to
go towards i take the cash from the
rental all right and i buy two cheaper
cars now this is gonna be painful joe
you're not gonna like this but i'm
giving you an option
but let's say you buy two ten thousand
dollar cars short term short term this
is just to kind of speed everything up
or even if you spent 30 on cars two 15
000 cash cars okay all right so
georgie's got about 35 cash left yep but
we've gotten rid of
the debt on the rental and we've gotten
rid of the debt on two cars we've taken
a huge chunk out of this and we still
have 35 000 to put towards the snowball
what's the payment on that rental
um it's actually dirt cheap it's um
350 a month okay so now we have 13.50
though back in your life to throw with
these other debts you see what we're
doing here and this is
food for thought
would it be worth you know
not throwing the 20 if we were putting
20 000 towards the cars
the used cars
would that be worth it even though these
interest rates are so high we would kind
of like
i guess we would
we wouldn't knock out that 20 000 worth
of the
student loan
and then we'd be getting hit with the 10
percent interest well you're staring at
the student loan but i'm looking at
13.50 in payments we can free up yeah we
just we just added 1 300 to your budget
so how quickly you eliminated yeah
so i like ken's plan i'm selling the
rental with the 65 you make we're going
to uh buy some reasonable cars let's say
30 grand worth of car leaving with 35
freeing up the rental payment freeing up
the car payments to now throw at the
remaining 150 in student loan debt
okay and with some sacrifices and making
200 grand now we're talking we can do
this in less than two years yeah this is
a scalable mountain but a joe i i think
you need these dramatic moves to speed
this up or else this is a a much longer
slog and and you know you guys with the
income and then we're not even talking
about your income potential down the
line as you guys grow in your career oh
yeah so and now is not the time to be
doing math the time to be doing math was
when we didn't go into 200 000 with debt
so let's focus on behavior right now and
changing the way that we look at money
and looking at our future as a newlywed
couple going where do we want to be five
years from now do we still want to be
climbing out of this mountain of debt
or do we want to be completely debt-free
making 200 grand a year more at that
point and we can really start living our
life yeah so that's what we want for you
and you can get another rental later we
can get a prius later they'll still
exist they're out there but right now
let's be about the business of cleaning
up this mess so we can utilize our
greatest wealth building tool our income
appreciate the call joe we're cheering
you on man it's gonna be hard but it's
gonna be worth it this is the ramsay
show
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print
joined by my fellow ramsay personality
ken coleman and host of the ken coleman
show we're taking your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
all right ken occasionally uh people
send me things on the internet yeah and
when enough people send me the same
thing i go all right i think we need to
talk about this
and you love a good headline and this
one caught my attention here it is you
ready for it i'm ready let's go bmw
heated seat subscription is real and it
costs 18
a month what get this here's the article
from motorone.com we've been warned
about how subscriptions could become the
automotive equivalent of a video games
downloadable content we're beginning to
see some more examples on its connected
drive store in south korea bmw owners
can pay a monthly fee to have a creature
comfort such as heated seats
it costs twenty four thousand won or
approximately eighteen dollars at
current exchange rates alternatively you
can get a one year plan for one hundred
and seventy six dollars or three year
subscription for 283 a similar
subscription plan is offered for heated
steering wheel and it costs 10 a month
okay i got questions you understand
what's happening here well i don't think
i do
because if you're paying for
the heated seats
and so let's say i sign up for this
nonsense because first of all i think
it's nonsensical it's ridiculous all
right but let's say i pay for it all
right
what happens if i'm if i'm delinquent
like i don't take the library book back
how are they turning the heat off in the
seats is it something it's all software
it's always software so they send the
code ken is current and then i can uh
have toasted activates your toasted buns
feature there you go okay so that's what
i see i was trying to figure out how do
they activate the heater
uh
this is a horrible light it continues on
you want wireless apple carplay that'll
be 305
one of the most unusual items found in
the bmw connected drive store is called
iconic sound sport it essentially plays
fake engine noises through the car
speakers should you be willing to pay
138 dollars to have the feature
permanently is this officially only in
south korea or is this
it sounds like it's starting in south
korea but i can see this taking uh let
me tell you something let me tell you no
way this lives in america no american is
willing to pay for that i'm willing to
put a fun bet on this i i think that it
is ludicrous i don't think americans
will do it i think they'll just say you
know forget it i'm not doing it like
every other car for crying out loud like
kia and like there's not exactly cars
anymore everybody's got the heated sure
but for example tesla self-driving it
exists the functionality's there but you
got to pay
to activate it
a peloton you buy a peloton well you got
to pay the 50 subscription fee if you
want access to all the content
in the screen on the pilot when every
other car on the market's got heated
seats unless you're driving something
past a certain age i think this is going
to hurt bmw it's going to hurt bmw it'll
never fly here it's ridiculous and don't
be sucked into this
i mean heard it here first sit on a
blanket what's happening is companies
are getting away with this whole digital
subscription monthly fee type service i
guess they can make more money okay let
me say this if you are in any type of
business if you can find a way to come
up with subscription revenue it is smart
i do believe that it is uh absolutely
the future this is not the way to do it
but not to nickel and dime for every
feature i'll tell you what i would so if
i'm bmw i'm trying to get subscription
revenue this is free advice bmw if
you're listening yeah i would be coming
up with uh exclusive content so bmw they
got some money they got some
relationships so maybe they go to they
go to uh uh who's a popular band right
now you know these things are harry
styles
oh geez
so then yeah but you got to think of the
bmw driver they don't care about what
are they listening frank sinatra or
something i don't know anyway the point
is i'd be coming up with unique content
that is only available through bmw
uh listen
so if you want subscription i can't
believe i'm doing the work for bmw this
is brilliant free consulting from ken
coleman anyway that's not heated seats
well i want people to pay attention to
their money and this is just not a good
use of it go find you a car that has
built-in heated seats
instead of you paying for it forever in
perpetuity you know what my dad did for
heated seats
what do you do he went and started the
car about 15 minutes early
cold days old school i mean come on go
start the car you got to hustle out
there it's a little abrupt the first
time you get in there but you fire the
car up you turn the heat on and guess
what the whole car is heated these are
some concepts some first world luxuries
we have ken i'll tell you that much
back in your day i mean you had to walk
uphill both ways you could get
respiratory arrests just doing that what
do you think i'm 70 george i don't know
come on all right gen x is a confusing
generation all right let's help zach
he's raising zach is on the line in
atlanta georgia he regrets the seven
minutes we just took up with that zach
how are you doing we're gonna get that
part of his life you'll never get it
back how can we help today zach
hey i'm not gonna be buying a bmw i can
tell you that hey that's what i'm
talking about another person helped
where's the tote board
what's going on with you um
so i'm 37 i'm a single dad uh my income
is my gross income is 104
and i don't have any debt except my
mortgage which i'm currently paying 500
a month extra torts going to pay my
house off early cool um
after all my other bills and ties that
leaves me about 1500 left over or 2 000
if i don't make any extra mortgage
payment and i've got about 5 000 saved
up in an emergency fund i'm putting i
did all the baby steps up to
um and including step four
so
i'm all caught up there
um i was just recently
divorced
during the divorce i worked a side job
uh or multiple side jobs to pay off
seventy thousand dollars of marital debt
um the support for the divorce and legal
fees um my ex-wife decided she wanted to
keep our marital residence
and um i was already out of the house of
course because of divorce so i agreed to
that even though the
mortgage was in my name only oh boy so
she didn't refinance into her name
well see that's the thing um
in the court order that was supposed to
happen but it didn't happen and um
about a year later
still hasn't happened agreed so um
the issue is that uh it can't happen and
so i have this house stuck in my name
um because she's not able to get a loan
for it
the house needs some work before it'll
be
it'll pass any kind of inspection we
bought it as a foreclosure fixer-upper
and we got about halfway through the
renovation work before
the divorce occurred so
i have this um
i have this issue and there is still a
little bit of legal stuff pending on
exactly how it's going to play out but i
have the expectation
uh i'm willing to take this house
because um
we owe or i owe in my name 178k on it
and uh the
appraisal
based on the
mortgage company and the comps in the
area that they say it's worth um over
400. whoa but it needs it needs work
yeah i'm thinking that too
so need some work to get it there um i
just started building up my emergency
fund and had a bunch of things go on
this year that kind of
emergencies that kind of dipped into
that so i don't really have a lot of
liquid cash
to i don't have any really to dump into
this house um now right now so
yeah
you have two grand of margin a month
that you could start socking away in the
savings account to cash flow these
repairs and renovations
correct okay
so i'd have to pay both mortgage
payments
because you're paying the one on your on
your own currently but also
on hers that she's living in is she
paying the mortgage
right now she is um because she is tilt
uh still technically living there um but
uh she's not
physically living there
very confusing somewhere else okay yes
it is very confusing well we need to get
down to the legal brass tax of when is
she getting out
and what does the financial piece look
like when you sell it because she's not
you know once she's gone you're going to
do these repairs and sell it right
that's what i would like to do
does she get proceeds from the sale
as part of the agreement that's
that's what we're trying to figure out
so
here's the problem zach you don't have
the cash to fix this house up and you
won't have it any time soon it's going
to take a lot
uh to fix this thing up to be able to
sell it for over 400 000 i'm going to
see what i can get as is for it and make
sure you know if the renovations are 20k
and it's only gonna appreciate by 15
then it's not worth doing the
renovations so i would work with a
realtor see what you could get for it as
is in this market and maybe go down that
path but before you do that i want to
make sure that what you're doing is
going to be worth it financially because
of this divorce this is real messy
so i talked with an attorney i'd work
with a real estate agent and start doing
that homework but man we got to clean
this up asap
wishing the best for you man this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
you know those moments when you're
sitting right next to someone but you
feel a thousand miles apart
some of you might be feeling that way
right now i am and this is a little
awkward to admit that jordan
two seconds away but ken's on his phone
he's distracted slide over ken is not
connecting
that's the problem we've gotta put our
phones down we've substituted deep and
meaningful conversations from binge
watching netflix and scrolling social
media and you guys deserve better
relationships and that means having
better conversations that's why our
friend mental health expert dr john
deloney created questions for humans
these are conversation starters that
will help you disconnect from screens
and actually connect and have fun with
the people you care about so we launched
the first edition of these cards a few
months back and they went gangbusters
flying off the shelves so you guys have
asked for more topics we took the hint
we've got new ones for you girls night
guys night dating parents and teens and
workplace additions have been added to
the lineup and all of them will get you
spending time laughing together learning
something unexpected and building deeper
and stronger relationships
so go ahead and pick up one two three of
our new questions for humans
conversation starters and start having
fun together you can find those at
ramseysolutions.com
i gotta talk to john and the team i got
an idea while you were talking about
that i think oh yeah i think it'd be a
good one i mean they got a million of
these things oh yeah they're clearly
looking for ideas what do you got uh
elevator edition
oh yeah you know elevator conversations
are very awkward you get an elevator a
bunch of you know you're at an office
building and it's just the awkward
silence you just go where are you headed
oh floor four good floor and i think i
think they need to you need one of those
because you know people aren't expecting
that one and we're going on the elevator
and then everybody's friends we're all
facing the door
you can't sit there and stare at the
person yeah in front of you that's
awkward right and then it feels weird to
have a conversation with someone behind
you and then there's the half full
elevator and then you're the one person
hopping on at floor number 15 and you're
going up to 28. you get it
you feel awkward you're breaking in on
the party
so i feel like this could this have some
likes this feels like a seinfeld episode
bring it back jerry bring it back all
right let's go man anyways what are we
doing we got our blinds.com question i
love i love blinds.com yeah their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
miss measure you pick the wrong color
they will remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more just use the promo
code ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from matt in iowa i have
a new job opportunity but i'm extremely
nervous to take the job because it is a
management position i've had leadership
roles in the past but this is my first
opportunity for management a little
confused by that statement we'll break
it down momentarily i'm 34 and i still
don't know if i'm ready for the job
because it's for a company that's
similar
but their terms for items are very
different than what i'm used to using am
i crazy to take the position or should i
stay at my 9 to 5 in a field i'm more
comfortable with i there's a lot going
on here matt and i uh
i don't think you're ready to take this
position for a multitude of reasons
um you've had leadership roles in the
past but this is my first opportunity
for management i truly don't understand
that
leadership assumes that you were leading
people yeah and thus management um
but here's what i'm seeing is is the
real red flag
it's a company that you said is similar
what you've done in the past but their
terms for items are very different and i
think what's going on here is a lot of
over
uh overthinking going on
and so i don't know if you're ready and
i think what you've got to do is
this might be something that you reach
out to some people that work in that
company and and get to the bottom of
maybe the language but they're going to
teach you the terminology or you're
going to adapt to the language so um i'd
be talking to people that work in the
company and get a good feel for is it a
good culture because if it's a healthy
culture
i wouldn't be worried about
learning new languages if you will
or business terms that's going to take
care of itself if it's a healthy place
because they're going to really onboard
you well and they're going to care for
you um i think the big issue and he
doesn't ask this george but
i'm seeing something in the data
where uh we're seeing a lot of
managers change jobs
in this so-called great resignation
and one of the things i was reading an
article a harvard business review
article about this is because here's
what happens when when companies see a
high performer okay they see a high
performer and they're not in a
leadership role or a management role but
they're doing a really good job and so
we want to reward them right and so
there are are really two ways to reward
people uh traditionally which is okay
we're gonna give you a raise and we're
gonna give you promotion more
responsibility
but there is a critical error that haps
that happens when you just assume well
george is really good at social media
and now we're going to move george into
a leadership leading other people in
social media well here's the deal
you may or not
may or may not really enjoy the role of
leadership oh you can teach leadership
you can teach good management to people
but if they don't enjoy it
it's not something that they you know
look forward to and to be put in that
role uh or maybe they don't have a great
skill set for that particular type of
leadership role then it ends up going
bad for everybody yeah the person you've
promoted into the leadership role
doesn't feel like it's a fit it becomes
obvious
and now we've got a problem because
we've rewarded a high performer who
performed well in this seat of the bus
but it's not performing well on this
seat of the bus and a lot of companies
are doing this and so if you are in that
position and you're facing a potential
promotion and you go i'm not sure
really dive into it look into it
what does the role require am i wired
for this first and foremost do i love
this type of work the majority of my day
does it produce results that i really
care about
and that's why we developed the get
clear career assessment to be able to
look at that kind of thing do i love the
work and does the work create results
that matter so
in this situation matt that's what
you've got to be doing you've got some
flag some red flags on your own
dive into it deep
uh to to be able to see is this fear
is it warranted yeah i go is this doubt
is this imposter syndrome because if
it's that we can learn we can grow some
confidence but if the red flags are
pointing to this ain't it for me yeah
that's okay too yeah but like you're
saying a great sales person gets
promoted to lead a sales team and coach
them well they may just love sales and
talking with people on the other side
yeah they may not want to coach
salespeople and you got to be able to
parse those out and have that
self-awareness good stuff thanks for the
question matthew joins us up next in
queens matthew welcome to the show
hey how are you guys great how can we
help today
thank you for taking my coral jordan
kind of appreciate it yeah
so me and my wife were just introduced
maybe about three months ago to george
uh to dave ramsey and um by the way i'm
a little nervous so you're there with me
you're doing great and
and we have a little bit of a dilemma
here and we're trying to see what's the
best way of going about it
um we're currently in baby step two um
aggressively paying back all our
consumer debt
but um after the consumer debt i have
the student loans that's about 200 grand
that i have to start paying back as of
september first and um
i'm a government employee and i qualify
for the public service loan forgiveness
as of 2025 so have a little bit a little
bit under three years or three years
to qualify for the loan forgiveness so
my question is
after baby step two with the consumer
debt should i
snowball into the into the student loans
or
should i take that time
and go into baby step 3 or
and have faith for the for the public
owned forgiveness or what should i do in
terms of you know putting all my eggs in
that basket so you're telling me in
three years you'll qualify as in they
will forgive the remainder of all loans
three years from now all 200k exactly
exactly all my federal student loans
which equivalent to 200 000 if if i when
i qualify which would be in three years
yeah because i'll be the 120 month mark
for me which is what's your other debt
that you have
uh i have 39 in credit card debt
unfortunately 90. okay uh i i got to ask
a quick question matthew is this a is
this is a guarantee this is actually an
already existing law or
uh executive order from from the
administration and because you're a
federal government employee is that what
i'm hearing
yeah so that that was my question as
well so i called i called them and i
because i honestly was thinking the same
thing you are a little bit skeptical
about it and they're telling me that
this is true and that i do qualify after
the after the 10 year mark which should
be in three years will be my 10-year
mark
and then my loans will be forgiven so
far from the information that i got
everyone that i spoke to only one person
actually
passed it and actually got it forgiven
no one else that i've spoken to have you
know been forgiven so i don't even know
how to approach this i'm i'm not going
to put my hope in it but i will do a lot
of research and if it's a sure thing
then i'm going to keep socking money
away in a savings account and three
years from now if it's forgiven you've
got a pile of money in your life and if
not you've got a pile of money to throw
at that debt but i'm not banking on it
until i got a real assurance that this
is gonna go through yeah george it
doesn't pass a smell test to me there
you go from the mouth of the horse
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day jeremiah 9 23
this is what the lord says
let not the wise boast of their wisdom
or the strong boasts of their strength
or the rich boast of their riches anne
frank one said human greatness does not
lie in wealth or power but in character
and goodness
i love that
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined today by ken coleman
shiloh joins us up next in dallas texas
shiloh welcome to the show
hi thank you how are you great how can
we help today
um so i graduated college in december
and i've been on the fence about going
and getting my master's in a different
field
and so right now i am an executive
assistant with my degree in business
administrator business management and
then i'm wanting to get my degree my
master's and in dietetics and go with
the registered dietitian route and so i
just don't know if that's like life's
choice financially or if i should stay
in the business field or what y'all's
opinion is yeah
well i you know shiloh i don't ever give
people advice to just hey you know stay
in the safe
uh career
that just it's a good check it's a it's
good benefits
because you're going to end up
regretting that and you are kicking the
tires on the idea of being a dietitian
for a reason i'm guessing
especially now so that you're actually
out there in the real world having got a
degree
and and you're in the business world and
yet you're still being pulled to being a
dietitian and i'm just curious what's
pulling you that direction
um i think that's what i always have
wanted to do i went into college as a
sophomore and then
i was so close to finishing my
uh
at
my associate's degree my parents were
like just finished that in business and
then maybe think about it well then
coveted hit and i was taking summer
classes so i graduated college in two
and a half years so i never really
stopped to think about redirecting
um but that's always still been what i
wanted to do okay you're gonna have to
humor me here because i don't know much
about you know the dietitian field
how much
value
is there in a master's degree
or is it an absolute requirement to
actually be a dietitian
so in 2024 it will be a requirement for
all registered dietitians to have a
master's degree
and most programs i found one program
where i can only get my like i can just
get my master's but most others make you
go pretty much have to have a a
bachelor's and a master's to
become a registered dietitian but the
one i found is careered towards um or
focused towards career changers and so
it allows you to go in with any um
all right so let me ask you this so you
got you could beat the 2024 rush
presumably correct
you could i mean once you once 24 2024
hits you're gonna have to go back and
get to your masters oh i see it's one of
those retro you'd have to go back and
get it okay i got i'm sorry i
misunderstood all right tell me this
what is that
yeah yeah what's the difference between
dietitian and
nutritionist a nutritionist you do not
have to have a degree um and you're
probably not going to be
uh your earnings are
like there's not as
much security in the position because
you don't have to have that degree and
you can just do trainings anyone can
call themselves a nutritionist but you
have to set for boards and exams to be a
registered dietitian and have a degree
okay and what is this master's degree
going to cost you
it would be around 40 000. okay and how
much cash do you have set aside for that
um so i had to take off work and be on
medical leave for about three months
and so right now i only have about 1500
in savings i have
a thousand
or about 1200 and a roth ira and then a
thousand an emergency fund okay
um so
so here's what i'm hearing is that you
really want to be a dietitian there's
some there's some you've always wanted
to be a dietitian have you spent any
time with a practicing dietitian or have
you just been so busy with school and
work okay so you've done enough research
even shadowing spending time with them
to know this would light my heart on
fire if i just snap my fingers right now
shiloh and you didn't have to get a
master's degree and i could put you in a
dietitian role you feel like hey this
would be so fulfilling this would be
something that i've always wanted to do
yeah okay well here's the deal
i got good news and bad news
the bad news is
you don't have the money right now
to be able to afford the masters
the good news is
you will eventually and the dietitian
role will still be relevant and still be
there so i think this is a buckle down
go really hard uh as a you know in in
the in the professional world you're
making a good salary you've had some
health issues and so you need to save up
some money but the reality is is that
you can save up forty thousand dollars
faster than you think you can even with
a second job selling stuff you know
whatever you got to do here's another
idea
look for the opportunity to get the
cheapest possible master's degree could
you find a master's degree in this
dietitian field that's less than forty
thousand if so do it because here's what
i can guarantee you shiloh
your ability to become a dietitian is
all based on you not where you get the
masters because you're still gonna have
to sit for the boards show them the
degree and nobody cares where you went
to school
want to challenge you shiloh i just did
a quick search and based on my search
dietitians and nutritionists about the
same median salary ah
so if that means i can be a nutritionist
and not get the master's degree and not
go thousand dollars into debt and do the
dream faster that might be an option for
you
okay and shiloh george thank you for
doing that because here's the thing no
seriously i was walking through i'm glad
you did the research
um
what if shiloh you could move from being
an executive assistant to be a
practicing nutritionist and get paid
well and being a good company or a good
situation and you're saving up and then
if you felt like okay to go to the next
level or to max out in this area
but at least you're in the field and
you're practicing you've got all this
experience and you're saving up money in
that field and then if you really feel
like down the road i want to get that
masters now we can cash flow what about
that option
right that sounds good i feel good about
this already what do you make as an
executive assistant
i'm at 50 right now yeah that's pretty
good i mean listen you can work your way
up in that if you go with the first
option you know
executive assistants can make as high as
six figures yeah in the right place the
right company that's why
so i was like well is that kind of like
silly to go back and go a different
route when it's not silly
no i just want you to do we want you to
do it the right way at the right place
what i'm saying is you can increase your
income as an executive assistant over
the next two to three years
which will allow you to make more money
if you don't want to go the nutritionist
route
and you want to do the dietitian route
and the masters what i'm saying is you
can grow professionally as an executive
assistant
i mean you got a degree in it i mean i'm
just trying to paint a positive picture
you can make really good money
save up money invest in your 401k you
have no debt get out of debt all that
stuff you know what i'm saying and then
cash flow your way through you've got
options
i just don't want you to go get us a
loan for a master's degree it's not
worth it
i'd rather you wait a couple of years
then go get the degree get the job
and be
digging out from underneath a mountain
of debt i don't want you to back
yourself into a corner where you you
imagine that you only have two options
one is go 40 000 into debt to do the
dream or the other is stay in a job i
don't like forever those aren't the
options and so i want you to just expand
your horizons and go hey what if i could
be an executive assistant for a
dietician
that would be cool get my foot in the
door proximity principle folks now i'm
in the field i want to be in and they'll
hire you on as you get the education
they might even pay for it folks like
the camel light bulb just went off ken
he's sharp i might go
i'm more excited than shiloh is
right right i'm pumped
about that hey what george said is
another really awesome option
you know
um you talk about getting into the field
and making things happen i i love this
so no debt right shiloh you're not going
to do not an option
right and then we get creative and go if
that's not an option how are we going to
get there what's the right path to where
we can do this and it's not going to
become a nightmare finally shiloh thank
you so much for calling us i love the
call we're pumped for you and my wife is
executive assistant so i got to say
shout out to all the executive
assistants out there it's very exciting
you make great money it's a great role
very exciting hey that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books my thanks
to ken coleman my co-host all the folks
in the booth you america will appreciate
you until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you